hallo mein name ist lukan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video letzten tage kamen auf einem kanal
über so ein bisschen dumme videos für
dich mal so sagen dieses liegen haben
uns jetzt halt gedacht wir machen etwas
mit mehr sind deswegen habe ich mir 300
bauarbeiter bestellt im internet die
kann man im mund packen und dann essen
wir tun als wäre mir die wange weiter
bekommen hast du natürlich hoch meter
tiefe für fünf euro
das leben ist schön
ich nehme schöne butterblumen wir reden
von leise wieso sollen laut dollar
ja
der geschichts- stolz dass ihr lied ist
sagt er vorhin ich bin fertig liegt eine
junge ich bin in bester kameramann wie
mainz und essen wie schnell luca mit
diesen dingern im mund das alphabet
aufnehmen kann und sagen wir starten auf
man sieht was drin steht und durch die
zähne
die chance und schonungslos gegessen
was halten sie von der liebe die lieder
über die liebe
14 ich hätte das nicht nur darf ich
fragen nicht
hier sehen sie eine rang genau wie bei
der ausbildung so ein paar sekunden
später
wäre schön wenn die kollegen so viel
scheiße ich ein großer kollegen dort ist
damit jeden tag zur arbeit zu gehen was
ihr enkel was sagen ich hatte einfach
konflikt der st
das leben nachzudenken zu können oder
wollen
wenn ich übers leben rät durch die
meisten ganz alleine auf smart aber auch
mit freunden viertel meinem
arbeitskollegen bodies lang gearbeitet
warum spannt er jetzt nicht
verantwortung seit dem haus
ich glaub da schleicht sich eine an
wir fragen gewittert lady oder typ
lederball oder hausarzt demetri oder
vassili petri insel oder der insel rang
oder bankdaten führerschein oder lang
lenkt lehre anke lehre mit matura oder
was sind das für raten- gute früher mit
bacon oder rum
eigentlich wollten wir das video echt so
aufbauen dass wir noch rein eigentlich
wollten wir das wieder so aufbauen dass
maxi nicht essen ein wettrennen
wettessen machen und wenn wir dran an
dieser stelle will ich jetzt aber dass
ihr beendet es wieder so richtig warm
geworden
falls es euch trotzdem vielleicht
gefallen hat benutzt beim live freuen
und wir sehen uns dann den ball in die
mitte